Fred and Rose were besotted with each
other absolutely besotted with each
other and it showed Rose was always a
little bit aloof but Fred was a true
gentleman
very friendly
um a very good landlord once I
eventually was asked to go through and
sometimes I go through to the kitchen to
take my washing through
um I'd I'd see Rose having a go at
Anne-Marie mostly
um because it seemed Ann Marie had to
get the children ready in the morning
for school and
you don't give them a piece of toast
without water so she was quite sort of
full-on with with Anne-Marie it seemed
like
they were unmarie's children not roses I
just happened to be in the living room
one night sat with them watching a movie
I can't remember why
and Fred was in the kitchen doing
something and the doorbell went
on a red light litter
and I just remember saying oh my
goodness it's like the red light area
and I was just
mom has her friends in there and we're
not allowed to go in